what's it hard to get ready no actually
you just did there I would have have the
weight of the ring would have made it
hard to know congratulations you guys
may we see the ring you did some good
work
it's amazing what you're my mystery
corner I'm still on cloud nine I still
can't believe that it happens oh yeah
robo place to me last night so it's all
a bit whoa Wow crazy still fresh
yeah it's still very fryer wedding for
an answer or two a long engagement I
guess thought about when you might want
to tie the knot I mean well now we'll
simply stop talking about all that but
why waste time you how does it feel to
take this journey together it's
incredible it's so amazing how we met a
year ago I never thought that I would be
you know meeting my future husband you
were so lucky we met our first day of
rehearsal we met during the day started
dancing and Robert had to leave to come
to the anjaan party and you have that we
met and then so it's all Berry's a full
circle moment it was a year ago today
that we met in